[Music]
okay so it's time to look at some of the
decline variation
and amongst them the first one which is
very popular
d4
whereupon i always get delighted as my
bishop can go to the c4 square
and now you can see the important of the
move a3 this bishop can always stuck in
on the a2 square
here my recommendation is you go with
the grand prix attack setup
so it doesn't matter whether black plays
e5 or c5 let's say
in one of the game black plays e5
white plays d3
and now
no matter whatever black plays we are
looking for this decisive f4 push
a model game from the database gives you
a very good idea
black plays knight to f6
white indeed goes f4
and now knight to c6 happen
okay knight to f3 pressurizing the e
pawn whereupon black defended with
bishop to d6
and after both the side castle
i really like white's play
first he played bishop to b5
threatening bishop takes c6 and then f
captures e5
something which black has to pay
attention immediately
so in the game
black plays queen to e7
but
this leads to the winning position for
the wide after the following transaction
bishop captures c6 pawn capture c6
f takes e5
bishop takes e5
knight takes e5
queen takes e5 and now this lovely move
bishop to f4
so there is an attack on c7 and if queen
to e7 then bishop to g5 is a very strong
reply
so in the game black plays queen to e5
other way to defend on c7
but after just one move knight to d2
that knight is coming on some juicy
square and i think in the game black
made the ultimate blunder
bishop to a6 which allow
this nice finish
knight to b3
double attack
queen to b6
but after bishop to e5
black simply resigned the game as
white has multiple threads and black
cannot parry all of them
so i think this game give you a great
illustration
how dangerous this line is for the black
the second move i want to consider is
knight to f6
which is kind of playing into the right
hand
because after e5
knight to d7 and d4
yes indeed we have the kind of french
defense structure
and whoever plays the advanced variation
knows the importance of a3 pawn because
after a sample line let's say c5
c3
and e6 we can play this thematic break
on the queen side with
b4 and all thanks to this little move a3
s after pontics and pawn takes
not only white has a space in the center
but his species can come out very freely
and attack black on the king's side
where it is very unlikely that after
playing the scandinavian defense
suddenly black switched to either french
or the car con
however in case this happened in your
case let me show you what my
recommendation is
so after your opponent plays e6 the
french i recommend you continue with e5
and
after the move c5
watch out for my attacking chess gambit
5
where i am going to show you this deadly
wing gambit starting with
b4
the point is after pawn takes
we are going to play d4
and
when black took the other pawn we
continue with c3
in this line white get tremendous attack
on the black king side
by putting knight to f3 bishop to d3
and i have covered each and every single
detail
in that video
so just wait for it
and look out this line in detail
what about caro khan starting with c6
well against all of this my
recommendation is you advance the pawn
on e5
and the main idea is after bishop to f5
he wants to play d4
when black plays e6
my recommendation is you continue with
knight to f3
and when black plays c5
you play bishop to e3
now white get a good advantage if black
continue with his most favorable choice
namely c captures d4
because after this white plays knight
takes d4 attacking the bishop bishop to
g6
and now remember this thematic break
c4 which already gives white a clear
advantage
one of the high profile game in the
database continue with
knight to e7
white pressurize the d-pawn with knight
to c3
and when black plays knight to c6
we have this technical sequence happen
on the ball
pawn takes d5
knight takes d5
y take on c6
whereupon black responded with knight
takes e3
but the end result is after queen takes
rook takes
knight takes d8
black also get the rook in the corner
with knight to c2
but when the dust is clear after king to
d1 knight captures rook and knight
captures b7 if you carefully count the
material
while clearly emerge
with an extra pawn advantage
so you can research this line in detail
and i am sure a scandinavian slash karo
khan player
are not that much prepared
for this nasty surprises
okay let's move on after d capture c4
knight to c3 and knight to f6
when we play queen to e2
apart from bishop to f5 black has other
choices
and amongst them the first choice is
queen to d4
now against this i recommend to play in
a pure gambit style starting with f3
and after pawn takes and knight takes
yes indeed white has sacrificed a pawn
but in return he get the leading
development
and just like black mod demo gambit we
have an open enf file which is always
good for the king side attack
here by far the most popular choice is
queen to d8
however if your opponent plays queen to
b6 then my recommendation is you play b4
and i have attached a sample line in the
pgn
okay queen to d8
afterwards we will play d4
grabbing the space in the center
and it is very difficult for black to
develop some of the pieces
for example he cannot play bishop to g4
in the view of queen to b5 check
e6 will make this bishop quite passive
so one of the most natural response here
for the black is to play knight to c6
pressurizing the d-pawn
but here comes
another deadly trick
starting with
bishop to g5
so you might says hang on you blunder
upon right
and indeed if black doesn't take it then
after white castles
white obtained a great advantage
so let's check out what is happening
after knight captures d4
whereupon i really like this cunning
sequence
knight takes d4 queen takes d4
and now you play this obvious move rook
to d1
well white queen has some natural
squares but they all leads to miserable
position
for example
queen to b6 looks very natural attacking
on the b2 pawn
but the problem is
capture on f6
whereupon
black is forced to capture with the
g-pawn
why what happened if queen takes
well the simple answer is you play
knight to b5 attacking on c7
and unfortunately for black he cannot
save it
if queen to b6
then we have this nice move queen to c4
renewing the thread
and c6
looks like saves everything
but see yourself
white has this nice queen sacrifice
queen to c5
black can't take it in the view of
knight to c7 checkmate
and not much he can do about it
for example this queen check is
completely harmless as after b4
black is indeed losing the game
so that means after bishop captures g5
here
black response is force he has to take
with the g pawn
but even after this we will continue
with
queen to b5 check
you can't take it or block it because of
knight to b5 so the force response is c6
but
we will take this queen and after pawn
takes
here comes the another deadly surprise
are you ready guys yup
knight to b5
once again that juicy fork is
unavoidable
[Music]
and if black take this 9
then we can throw this bishop to bifa
check
which not only regain the peace
but the end result is
completely favoring the white camp
so these are some of the wonderful
tricks exist
if you open and continue with queen to
d8
last but not least
probably the most critical response here
is knight to c6
allowing white to regain his spawn
but black's big idea is he wants to play
knight to d4 attacking the white queen
now against this my recommendation is
you continue with knight captures ap6
first
destroying the black pawn structure
and then play the move queen to d1
yes indeed we have no development
but we have done our work that is
compromising black pawn structure
here if your opponent plays bishop to g4
then bishop to e2 is a strong reply
however if you check this position in
online database
bishop to f5 has been highestly played
here
which looks natural but after the
following sequence
d3
e5 and now knight to e2
what is coming on top in each line
for example i can show you one of my
game against the low rated opponent
where he continue with bishop to c5 i
chop on d4 and after bishop takes
white can play the move c3
the big point is after bishop to b6
white has this nasty surprise queen to
f3 a double attack
b7 as well as on f5 bishop
so my opponent choose the move queen to
c8 defending both the threat
but after bishop to e3
black to his horror find out that he
cannot castle
in the view of
bishop to at6
so he thought ok i will take this bishop
first
and after i recapture with the pawn
suddenly white is in a completely
driver's seat
as we have a simple threat namely e4
and then gobble up the f6 bomb
you can try by yourself but it is very
hard to defend this position
as my opponent continue with queen to e6
but then i safely take on b7
and after white castle
[Music]
i do not want to take on c7
and give black some tempo
so i simply retrieve back the queen
and the end result is
we have an extra pawn and the simple
plan namely e4 bishop to e2 and castle
with all together
some horrible pawn structure for the
black
gives white a completely winning age
that's it guys i hope with this analysis
now you're confident enough to include
this line in your rapprota as a complete
surprise weapon
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and i
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care